the new LeBron James Museum just opened
in akan and it's a must seed for any
LeBron fan first off we get to walk into
a recreation of the apartment room where
LeBron grew up and one of the underrated
Parts is getting the chance to see some
of the college offers that LeBron
received at the time shout out to Gloria
James for saving those and of course the
museum has a lot of original LeBron
apparel including game one jerseys and
sneakers that take you through all the
championship Seasons he had but these
next two on the list might be the most
amazing things in the museum yet the
museum has the all white suit that
LeBron wore on draft night they even
managed to get the draft board from when
he was drafted Oh and by the way did we
mention that it's only $23 to get in
Lebron obviously still has love for the
fans even though he beat the Cavs on the
day the museum open but still all the
money made from it will be going back to
the community Through the LeBron James
Family Foundation